i have friends that are
um most excited about
anti-racist work through the lens of
being parents right
and what history classes we took and
what things we learned about the united
states and like how do how will that
look for this next generation and so
uh i'm very interested in that um
and i i'll be completely honest i
haven't had those kind of i haven't
begun those conversations he has a hard
time sitting still and
we you know he's too young he's into
coral reefs and things
like that but i i but but not too far
off to be honest and
you know i was speaking to some other
dad friends um
where you know especially last summer
here
uh living in uptown and the the very
organized
peaceful protests and some of the riots
like i remember seeing it
um whether it was on tv or just
listening just out my front window and
thinking like i got to be out there
that's i want to be
in the mix with people mm-hmm
one of the leaders in san francisco
reminded me this week that like there
are
there are other ways that you can have
as much or much more impact but
but going back to what we said earlier
about who i am and how i connect and how
i participate yeah i would imagine
you're like
you need to be right i'm like honey i
gotta go and she's like you're not
leaving us
here that vibe and so that was a real
push-pull for like the fatherhood thing
of like
what is your responsibility right and
right and and where is your time best
man
yeah and so um you know but i i did and
i still do take him out on the bike seat
little bike seat on the back
dad life man tuck in the shirt kid goes
in the back and um
and we uh we would go to some peaceful
marches and protests and things and i
would talk about how these are mommy and
daddy's friends and everyone's wearing
black and and um black lives matter and
we've been to the george
floyd uh memorial now it's called george
floyd square
um i went once by myself and then the
next day i took just
just lumi um i didn't let goldie know
but then the three of us went the next
day um
[Music]
which has its own which has its own
kind of set of opinions which is just
kind of this tourist vibe of like
going to the place where this unarmed
black man was killed yeah
which is something we're gonna i think
we're gonna do after this podcast right
and it is a loaded thing like you don't
want to be a looky lou like how do you
approach that
with the correct level of like respect
and appreciation
it's not about your instagram moment
yeah i mean and this was a conversation
that came up with knox when he visited
you know i said i said to him and i said
to you which is like
um if we don't go i understand
from a personal uh
point of view i think
i think it's i think it's important any
steps closer you can take to
the reality i encourage and i know i'll
get blowback for just even saying that
and
and for me to take my kid there and my
wife and we have we took pictures and
you know
um again supercharged with privilege but
like
george floyd and our move to minneapolis
and i don't know how much longer we'll
be here we could
he could you know go to college at the u
you know this could be where we are
forever but if we aren't
or if we are his first history lesson
that he lived through that he knows is
george floyd and we and we we went to
the place where he was
murdered in broad daylight and i
i look if if that if there's some
judgment there and
um i not only do i understand it but i
like i see it um
and at the same time like i think
i think keeping kids in cocoons and not
not telling these stories
is absolutely wrong yeah 100 so then
so then it's you know
you know that corner on chicago ave is
you know point four from where we lived
you know
i ride my bike on every corner of the
city so yeah we're gonna go
[Music]
you